[Music]
i can pull that fat cat down i can bring
him right off this hill
[Music]
do you know that that money that money
is made out of my father's flesh i've
had more than most actors i have had the
opportunity to work in films that
transcended their times mom
this is john
it is my nature to make the kind of film
that would make a comment
i'm pleased to meet you mr street there
are great actors and there are important
actors sidney poitier was both how did i
break through i think i had
great good luck on my side and i also
think i came along historically at the
right time
city was raised in the bahamas where his
father was a tomato farmer i left the
bahamas i left the caribbean and i went
to new york
at the age of 15
and i survived there with no friends no
money no relations
no one
sydney acted in more than 40 films and
inspired a generation especially oprah
winfrey they call me mr tibbs
they call me mr tibbs i want to ask you
about sidney poitier's
importance in hollywood and i say that
in not just his movies
but his position in hollywood there is
no one on earth
i
love more
there's no one who i have greater
respect or regard for
sydney was the first black man to win an
academy award lilies of the field earned
him the oscar for best actor and that
night in 1964 impacted a ten-year-old
oprah and countless others forever the
winner is sydney portland
i still see the image of him when anne
bancroft hands him the academy award
and
i was
profoundly when i tell you profoundly i
could start weeping right now i was
profoundly deeply
sincerely moved by that moment because i
had never seen we were being called
colored people at the time i had never
seen
a colored man
look like that and i just thought if he
could do that
i wonder what i could do wow
and that was at 10 years old and because
he did that
i was able to do what i have been able
to do in the world and every single
other black person who followed
it only happened because he was able not
just to do that
but to be that
can you briefly recall for me how you
felt the night you got your award it was
extraordinary it was remarkable it was
like
[Music]
it was great what can i tell you
what can i give you in return
some of his most memorable roles
included playing a high school teacher
in working class london in to serve with
love and a detective in the deep south
in in the heat of the night what works
of his really touch you i love guess
who's coming to dinner because the scene
and guess who's coming to dinner where
he says but you think of yourself as a
colored man man and i think of myself as
a man
that is who he is
cindy was also a mentor to denzel
washington when he was a young unknown
actor denzel met his idol in a bookstore
i took out my picture and resume
did you really sure did he was like well
son i don't think this is the
appropriate place
it's okay i'm doing it anyway i did it
anyway he didn't take it but it was cool
he was young he was skinny
then there was
but there was the flavor
of what was to come i got to know him
quite well after that
and
you know this is one remarkable
actor
the first time i met him at quincy
jones's house uh we had a conversation
and i was telling him about how hard it
was because i was getting so much
criticism from black people who were
saying i wasn't i was hugging white
people too much i wasn't doing enough of
this and i should be more of that and
and he said
this is what happens when you carry
people's dreams
and
after that conversation he agreed to
come on the oprah show
it's the one time in my life where i had
a breakdown after the show you didn't
believe the dogma you didn't believe
what people said was possible for a
black man well from the very beginning i
didn't believe that i finished interview
viewing him kevin
and i went into the control room
and i
laid my head down on the desk in front
of the producer and i just bawled
i'm such an idiot he's going to hate me
i didn't ask any good questions he's
he's never going to speak to me again
you know it it was one of those things
where you meet the person you most
wanted to meet and then you felt like
you were not good enough
but after that he gives me a call
and he says he's calling me to apologize
because he did not feel that he was his
best that day and after that we were
friends forever i don't think the
dictionary has sufficient words
descriptive enough
to really
explain articulate define
oprah winfrey
she is a phenomenon
sydney told us his happiest times were
with his loved ones he was married twice
and had six daughters we were on set of
the 1997 movie free of eden where his
daughter also named sydney was starting
her own acting career my daughter has a
history
and the history is one in which
when mom and i
kind of
let her know that we are pleased about
something or a direction she's about to
take
she changed gears on us and she goes
somewhere else
so when she started in this business we
kept our mouths shut
sydney also tirelessly worked to
champion human rights and equality for
all even helping to finance the civil
rights movement always striving to
improve himself and the world around him
he once said i always wanted to be
someone better the next day than i was
the day before there's always
room for improvement
at my age what am i going to do
[Music]
die
certainly i will one day but until that
moment when i am no more there is room
for improvement